hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the foods that have the most
potassium
number one is beet tops okay now what I
like to do is take the beets take the
tops off put them in a blender with your
kale to make a kale shake okay you can
do that or put it into your salad but
one cup is 1300 milligrams of potassium
that is a lot this is also good for your
gall bladder in the liver
number two is avocado okay 975
milligrams per avvocato that's pretty
good now there is one food that has a
little more potassium avocado
but I'm not recommending it because it's
not on the program but potato potato has
like about a thousand milligrams of
potassium but we're not going to
recommend it okay lima beans have 975
it's pretty good
I don't recommend beans though for most
people but for some people they can
include them but just make sure that
your total per day carbohydrates don't
exceed 20 to 50 grams and the problem 1
cup of lima beans is 39 grams of carbs
but you have the fiber which is 13 so if
we deduct that we get the net carbs of
26 grams of carbs per cup so that's
gonna eat up a lot of your carbs for one
day and you could do it as long as you
don't exceed the total carb per day
spinach 839 milligrams that's pretty
good then we have squash 800 and these
are basically one cup okay one cup of
each of these equals this right here now
salmon 839 not per cup but per 6 ounces
okay then we have Brussels sprouts this
is per cup 504 milligrams of potassium
there we have it use out of the top
potassium foods thanks for watching
hey guys a lot of you already have my
book some of you don't but this new
edition called the new body type guide
is an upgrade from my last Edition
called the 7 principles of fat burning
it has 156 images 378 pages full
glossary I talk about Kido
in a minute-- fasting the body types in
detail I have a new stressed chapter I'm
going to show you exactly what to eat
any comprehensive FAQ I put a link down
below check it out